that's got to be a mistake that can't be
right
kelly ripa getting candid about the
moment she learned regis philbin died
there was a moment where i had this uh
incredible hope
that it was somehow misreported the 49
year old talk show host opens up about
the
impact the tv icon had on her in an
upcoming 2020 special titled
regis philbin the morning maestro kelly
co-hosted live with regis and kelly from
2001 to 2011
after replacing kathie lee gifford she
continues to host the show today with
ryan seacrest
i think my biggest takeaway from the 11
years that i
shared with him was that you have to be
yourself
you cannot be one person on camera
and a different person once the
light goes off or the audience is gone
you have to be
who you are in a sneak peek at the
special kelly reveals at first
she didn't believe the news that regis
had died at the age of 88
something she also said on live with
kelly and ryan on monday
as people get older
you you know you always know that some
certain things are inevitable and
passing away is one of those things but
regis is one of the people that we all
believed
i think would somehow
figure out a way around the inevitable
kelly also said her heart
went out to his family the first person
i thought of
was joy and and joanna and jj
his daughters i thought of the girls you
know and then i
thought of kathie lee and those were i
always say like
regis core four right the core four his
girls
is there anything you wish you could do
over no i really can't think of anything
i think i was very good with with kathie
lee with kelly
um i'm thank god i had them
kelly previously paid her respects on
instagram writing that regis
was the ultimate class act adding that
she was beyond lucky to have him as a
mentor i got presents today from regis
she got a free mug
that's right and in the upcoming special
kelly said she got emotional seeing a
throwback clip of regis
babysitting her kids with hubby mark
consuelos i
got particularly emotional when we
saw those clips
okay that's good i mean that's good just
the way he
spoke to her in this very sweet
way if all that wasn't sweet enough
kelly explains what she thinks made reed
so special his talent was
um being himself completely
um and making
everybody else the star of the show
i think his love of people will also be
his legacy